it's 2016 and today is the first day of
2016
Patriot male the right of the people to
keep and bear hates shall not be
infringed Patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom very very
aggressive on hatred mail to start off
the year okay let's take a listen to
this one together
David [ __ ] man should be your name
common sense is not in your genetics
your mother dropped you and that
drooling liberal idiot that sometimes is
across from you seriously think that by
accepting people that have been
infiltrated by Isis and Isis says they
will use the refugees to bring
terrorists into other countries and you
want to give them a nice big hug yeah
you're gonna be hugging a stump crying
when they chop your head off
you two are [ __ ] absolutely the
longest run on sentence in the history
of hatred mail Lewis to start 2016 what
is your analysis or interpretation of
the fact that you are taking more and
more heat in hatred mail lately do you
think that this is a sign that you are
making an impact and people are really
picking up on what you're saying or do
you think something has changed and
people are particularly disgusted with
you lately I think it just means that
more people are watching the show and so
more people are aware of me and that
leads to more hate reott ism directed at
me yesterday on twitter this is so funny
i didn't even mention this to you
someone was tweeting to me about how
they just couldn't stand what tommy said
on the show and i was like there was
this multi tweet rant about Tommy and I
said who on earth is taht is Tommy a
caller are they referring to a guest and
they were talking about Louis
I mean lit they said lady they referred
to Louis as Tommy they were convinced
that the co-host of the show was Tommy
and I said I have no idea who that is
maybe they got that from my last name
Motamedi that's Ronnie my comedy now
that's it that's a fake name if I've
ever heard one before yeah hate
male starting 2016 off strong and we
already have some absolute gems for you
for the next couple of weeks so uh it's
gonna be quite a year in hatred male
election years are crazy years for
hatred mail that's for sure